hey 42 here i've heard it said that you
have to speculate to accumulate
and that's absolutely true
but there's a flip side to that catchy
phrase speculating is also a pretty
great way to lose every penny you own
if you're ever unlucky enough to find
yourself in that unfortunate position
there are two main ways of dealing with
your loss
either you can throw in the towel and
accept the crappy hand fate has dealt
you or you can pick yourself up dust
yourself down and declare yourself the
supreme leader of whichever country you
happen to live in
one person who opted for that second
option which i admit was a bit of a
curveball was a formally successful san
francisco businessman who bankrupted
himself by speculating on of all things
the price of rice
and what happened next is quite simply
one of the weirdest and most
heartwarming tales i've ever covered on
this channel
this is the story of joshua norton the
first and last emperor of the united
states of america
now i can guarantee that none of you
have heard the story of the 195 million
dollar bullet back in 1964 the most
popular artist in the world andy warhol
had just finished a series of four
canvases depicting marilyn monroe in his
famous pop art style so when a
photographer friend asked if he could
shoot the portraits he assumed she was
talking about taking photos imagine his
surprise when she pulled a pistol out of
her purse and fired a single bullet
piercing three of the four canvases
right through marilyn's forehead fast
forward to a few weeks ago and one of
the portraits shot blue marilyn sells at
auction for 195 million dollars smashing
the auction record for a 20th century
artwork it sounds unbelievable but this
track record of contemporary arts
delivering insane returns is exactly
what inspired a unicorn startup called
masterworks to open the art market to
the public at large speaking of returns
each of the three paintings masterworks
has sold so far after offering them to
their members have returned over 30 net
now legally i have to add past
performance is no guarantee of future
results but i've talked about
masterworks on the tunnel before because
i think what they're doing is genius the
art market isn't reserved for the ultra
wealthy in fact members of the 42
community have already invested with
masterworks with the stock market being
crazy recently now's the perfect time to
diversify your portfolio and masterworks
is how i'm choosing to do that and
luckily for you masterworks has provided
my viewers with priority access so go
check them out and see the new offering
they have on their platform using the
link in the description below thanks to
masterworks for sponsoring this video
exactly when joshua abraham norton was
born has been lost to the sands of time
but most norton scholars believe it was
probably in early february of 1818.
that being the case norton would have
been just two years old when his parents
packed their bags and left their home in
england behind to set sail for south
africa where the british had recently
established a colony
not much is known about norton's
formative years in south africa
nor what it was that convinced him to
leave it 25 years later
but what we do know is that by the late
1840s norton had packed up his life in
africa and made his way to america and
specifically san francisco
norton was a bright guy and talented
businessman and within the space of just
a few short years he'd proven just how
apt america's reputation as the land of
opportunity really was by amassing a
good chunk of cash through a series of
successful real estate ventures and a
certain knack for commodities trading
all told norton accumulated some 250 000
in those early years
that's about 10 million dollars in
today's money and it seems that being
rich was just as op back in the 19th
century as it is today
because norton's wealth helped him rise
to become one of the most important and
respected figures in the whole of san
francisco he was invited to the fanciest
parties and consulted on the most
important topics of the day
he wore fine clothes ate it the best
restaurants and lived in a grand mtv
cribs worthy mansion
but just when it seemed norton was
poised to become a playboy of
gatsby-like proportions
one bad deal brought everything he'd
built crashing down around him
and all it took was 90 000 kilograms
of rice
around the time norton arrived in
america famine was spreading across
large parts of china
in an attempt to avoid an all-out
catastrophe a ban was placed on the
export of rice a move that saw its price
rocket around the world
so when a ship laden with peruvian rice
sailed into san francisco bay in late
1852
not long after the chinese export ban
was imposed joshua norton's eyes did
that spinning dollar signs thing you
sometimes see in the cartoons acting
fast he snapped up the entire shipment
for twenty five thousand dollars about a
million in today's money
then he simply sat back lit a giant
cigar
probably and waited for the price of
rice to saw
and that's exactly what it did
for all of about 24 hours
that's how long it took for the next
ship stuffed filter bursting with
peruvian rice to arrive in san francisco
and over the next couple of weeks
several more ships followed
not only was there now far more rice
available than norton had anticipated
the lot he purchased was pretty much the
worst of them all in terms of quality
far from earning a tidy profit in less
than a month norton's investment had
lost 90 percent of its original value
as i've said norton was a rich man by
this time and had he simply accepted his
loss and moved on
i probably wouldn't be making this video
but
as it happened
he'd only actually paid a 2 000
upfront fee for the rice with the rest
of the contract due at a later date and
nowadays it was clear that the price was
anything but right
norton flatly refused to settle the
balance
a two-year legal battle followed with
the case eventually ending up in front
of the california supreme court
norton lost and when the damages legal
fees and lost earnings had been tutted
up
he was left with the square root of
bugarol
well that and a shitload of rice
the effect all of this had on norton was
considerable the lavish parties and
expensive cloves were gone
as was the swanky san francisco mansion
he was flat broke and his friends
influence and good standing were a
distant memory
nobody really knows whether the whole
ordeal simply pushed norton's sanity to
breaking point
or if what came next was the inevitable
evolution of a man who was apparently a
lot more eccentric than anyone had
noticed during the good times
whichever it was it soon became clear
that norton had no intention of
accepting his new lower station in life
[Music]
in 1858 several years after the ruinous
rice write-off when a penniless norton
was living in a boarding house he
decided to run for congress perhaps
unsurprisingly this somewhat ambitious
career move ended in failure
but norton didn't let that hold him back
if the good people of the united states
of america didn't have the wherewithal
to elect him to a position of power
he was simply going to have to take the
decision out of their hands
in the autumn of the following year
norton arrived at the offices of the san
francisco daily evening bulletin
armed with a handwritten letter
this is what it said
at the preemptory request and desire of
a large majority of the citizens of the
united states i joshua norton formerly
of algoa bay cape of good hope and now
for the last nine years and ten months
past of san francisco california
declare and proclaim myself
emperor of these united states
after he'd stopped laughing the editor
at the san francisco daily evening
bulletin did something quite unexpected
he agreed to publish norton's letter
the decision was motivated more by the
comedy value of norton's preposterous
statement than the fact the editor had
just been given a world exclusive by the
usa's first ever emperor
but even so the declaration was
published and the rest is history
norton's 21-year reign as the
self-proclaimed emperor of the united
states of america
had just begun
the first thing on the new emperor's
agenda was to sort out the rabble who'd
been doing such a crappy job running the
country before him
norton considered congress to be full of
fraud and corruption he'd have fit
writing in 2022 wouldn't he and so one
of his first official decrees was to
abolish it entirely
three months later when it had become
clear that the big wigs in washington
had no intention of packing up and going
home
no matter what the crazy guy in san
francisco thought
emperor norton realized it was time to
get serious and so he ordered the man
they called old stuff and feathers
commanding general of the us army
winfield scott to forcibly remove
washington's elected officials from
their posts unfortunately this perfectly
reasonable royal decree was ignored too
now to tell the truth the majority of
emperor norton's 250-plus edicts
delivered over his two decades in charge
of the united states
were completely ignored
the majority but remarkably enough
not all
i'll get to that in a minute
norton took his job as leader of the
free world incredibly seriously by day
he could be seen doing his rounds of san
francisco inspecting the local
infrastructure making state visits to
the city parks and visiting the office
of newspapers to dish out more decrees
and proclamations he looked the part too
norton was never seen out of full royal
attire
which consisted of a rather fetching
blue uniform with gold-plated epaulettes
a beaver fur hat topped with a jaunty
peacock feather and either a ceremonial
saber or a stately cane depending on how
badass he was feeling on that particular
day
notson was so serious about his role as
monarch that he even issued his own
currency premisery notes in
denominations of 50 cents to 10
plenty of local businesses actually
accepted them too
norton's made up money was good enough
for many of san francisco's best
restaurants where he ate on a nightly
basis and a large number of shops and
restaurants hung signs in their windows
reading by appointments to his majesty
emperor norton the first
you might be thinking that any business
owner who accepted fictional currency
from a made-up king was clearly an
absolute mug
if so you'd be dead wrong
today the few surviving examples of
emperor norton's premisery notes sell at
auction for up to 15 000
apiece
with so much time having passed since
norton's day it's difficult to say for
certain whether or not the emperor of
the united states
was simply an eccentric man who'd fallen
on hard times
or someone suffering from genuine mental
illness who truly believed he was
running the country
but the latter is certainly a
possibility
one that was considered even back in
norton's day
he was once arrested by a member of san
francisco's police force who planned to
have norton tried for insanity it would
have been interesting to know what an
expert might have made of norton but no
assessment was ever carried out because
the arrest triggered a huge backlash
amongst the people of the city
not to mention several local newspapers
nawsom was released soon afterwards and
issued with a formal apology
not one to hold a grudge norton
responded in kind but stirring an
official pardon on the police officer
who'd arrested him
from that day forward norton was saluted
by every single policeman who passed him
in the streets of san francisco
you have to admit the whole thing was a
genuinely weird situation
on the one hand people obviously knew
that emperor norton wasn't actually
running the country
but for the most part he was treated as
though he was doing exactly that
and it wasn't just the locals in san
fran who were playing along if you were
to take a look at the 1870 u.s census
you'd find norton's official occupation
listed
as emperor
and it's even rumored that kamiyama had
v
at the time the king of hawaii grew so
annoyed with the us government that he
formally recognized norton as the one
true leader of the united states by the
way as a completely random aside if the
name kamiyama had v sounds oddly
familiar to you it may be that you're a
dragon ball z fan
goku's famous finishing move was for
reasons that are hard to explain named
after the hawaiian king
anyway over the years norton became such
an influential figure in his own strange
way
that newspaper started to print fake
declarations from the emperor in an
attempt to achieve their own goals
so many of these fake proclamations were
printed that these days it's difficult
to know which ones were actually his
but the thing is
for all his pomp circumstance and
possible insanity emperor norton
actually had some bloody good ideas
for example in one decree he called for
the formation of a global league of
nations to work towards such noble goals
as world peace an organization very much
like the one norton described was
founded in 1945
more than six decades after his death
today we know it as the united nations
in the 1870s norton also decreed that
either a suspension bridge or a tunnel
be built to improve the connection
between oakland and san francisco
almost 60 years later the now world
famous bay bridge opened to the public
for the first time
and the trans bay tube a tunnel
connecting oakland and san francisco
that like the bay bridge was built
exactly where norton proposed it should
be
came about 40 years after that
norton was also light years ahead of his
time when it came to things like
equality and religion he decreed that
people of all skin colours be allowed to
ride in streetcars and attend schools a
truly radical idea in mid 19th century
america he believed in votes for women
something that didn't actually happen
until 1920
and he made declarations advocating the
separation of church and state and
forbidding conflict between religions
all things considered it might not have
been such a bad thing
if emperor norton actually had been the
leader of the free world
but sadly even the most illustrious of
royal reigns must someday come to an end
and for norton that day came on the 8th
of january 1880 when he collapsed whilst
walking the streets of san francisco the
city he loved and that had come to love
him he died before help could arrive
the funeral was held two days later and
according to newspaper articles printed
at the time as many as 10 000 people
came to pay their respects to the fallen
emperor
in keeping with norton's almost mythical
status
it had long been speculated that he was
actually fabulously wealthy and merely
pretending to be a crazy old guy to
throw people off the scent
there were even rumors that he was the
son of napoleon iii the last monarch to
rule over france
he wasn't
obviously
and one look at his shabby apartment
laid those stories of fabulous wealth to
rest
despite his frankly remarkable life and
the surprising level of power he wielded
norton died a pauper with just a couple
of dollars to his name but his story is
such a strange one that it's inspired
the work of countless writers and
creatives ever since you can find norton
doing his crazy thing in the pages of
novels by mark twain and robert louis
stevenson
in the cells of comics written by neil
gaiman and in a whole host of different
tv series and films his name checks in
popular culture are admittedly somewhat
less frequent than they used to be but
for my money that's a shame when life
gave joshua norton lemons
he made lemonade
and then spent the next two decades
insisting he was leader of the free
world
and the best thing is
somehow against all the odds
it kind of worked
thanks for watching